في الاثناء قال الرئيس الاوكراني
وفلوديمير زيلينس كانه يعود الى بلاده بعد
جولته الاوروبيه محملا بحزم دفاع جديده
وبالمزيد من الاسلحه الاكثر قوه للجبهه
وبالمزيد من الدعم السياسي واضاف زيلينسكي
انه زار القاعده العسكريه في اخ وطلع على
تدريبات جنوده على الاسلحه الالمانيه
نعود الى الوطن بحزم دفاع مع المزيد من
الاسلحه الجديده والاكثر قوه للجبهه
والمزيد من الدعم السياسي شكرا لايطاليا
على مساعدتها في حمايه ارواح شعبنا
بالاضافه الى برلين قمنا ايضا بزياره اخ
واطلعت على تدريبات جنودنا على المعدات
الالمانيه كما عقدت مباحثات طويله ومفيده
مع السيد الرئيس ماكرون واتفقنا على صفقه
عسكريه وترتيبات سياسيه جديده